>>> IN OUR WORLDEAEV
U.S. BORDER ENPOTSMEXICO ARE BL.
THIS AFTER LARGE CROWDS TRIED TO
CASRUPTION  LEAST THREE DIFFERET
L EYES ARE ON THE
BORDER, THE NORTHERN O O
OWN SET O
IML VIONE
UNTRY A NORTHERN
TH'S
D ES ANDr: ON A LONE FROZEN REH
DEAD.E U.S. ANDEEUNG.
ANOS
BORDER HERE IS TOLD BY CANADIA
AUTHORITIETH
IMMEDIATELY ARRESTED.
E HAVE TO ADSE IT'
ER
>> RIGHTOU'RE DER ARREST
>> IT'S ILLEGA ENTER CANADA RE.
WARNINGS ARE EVERYONE ON THIS IG
PEOPLE, MANY O HAVE
COBBLED TOGETHER A WAYO GETO
THEN PAY AR TOEM UTH O AND
OFF AT THIS  CORRIDOR.ARE OF WH
>>LET ME SEE A AT.
>>COMEER PROVI
THEM WITH WARM T'LNE IT'OKAY.
>> Reporter: PEOPLE FROM ALL
CROSSIN
TH
TEAR
TEARS TELLS ME SHE'S BEEN
MANY DAYS TO G
SHE SAYS AND HERLDEDOR SAS LASTL
COLUMA THREATENED TO KILL
SH C
HE A FFEEL LIKE I CAN HA B
IFE IN CANAD
INSTEAD OF REMAININGTHE
AFR DENT TO JOINE ASYLUM IN CAN
ISN'T EAR.
TH FEW YEARS HAVE SEENLU C CANA
T O HA GETTINGN APPOINTMEN
EBRUARY  ACAN
SO TWO YEAep DULA HELPS LEAD THE
FR TRS USED TO  HISTORICALLY A.
>>HE NON-PROFIT RKING WITH TADI
GOVERNMENT T GUIDE
REFUGEES THROUGH THESY
W AN
JA>> RepteRES SHOW A RECOR00
UNAUTHORIZED ENTRIES INTQUEBECON
ROUG R
U.S. AND CANADIAN OFFICIALS AR
DISCUSSING POTENTIAL CHAES TO
E   LOOPHOLE IN THAT
ICENTIVIZCOMING FROM THE OA OS
TO RENEGOTIATE THEAF EMENT WITHE
STATES.
>> Reporter:
NTS FROM MEXICO AR
KIS
SOUTH.THE  BORDEPAHOWING E IMAG
SUBZO ER
NCREASEDSOUTHBOUND FLOW OF MIGR.
SIN THERD PARIS